welcome to this video playing
grandmaster soon about hans
drain you
um
yeah okay
it was bad yeah i should have played it
in the other move order but okay i want
to do something else i played the queen
b3 slav
against him a number of times
and it didn't lead to anything
bishop f5 of course is super solid
there are some some other lines that
give a little bit more hope
for um
for some play
but maybe he's not
such a huge expert here you never know
bishop
b4 now is
clearly the best
yeah bishop c6
or castle so you can do both i know
castle
okay is this some way here forward
queen a3 maybe
queen b6 i'm going to take rook c1 yeah
that's really nothing
big f5 is really like totally totally
equal
so it's trying to do something with g5
or
g5 possibly knight to d2 this this kind
of things
yeah should i save the bishop maybe i
should
and also prevent g-form like
like that okay he's insisting on on
doing that
so if i take on c6
yeah i'm not sure if this
is that great weakening
weakening uh the the whole
the whole king side like that
when you at the same time do stuff here
with your rook i rook a6 i am
overlooking very simple stuff here
of course he's playing rook a6 what else
yeah and now f6 yeah and the whole thing
is um
it's tricky
knight d3
92 rook d1 knight c4 queen c3
maybe
yeah he has rook a6 all the time
for at least the draw but definitely
black is calling the shots here with his
space advantage
um
yeah that's not that's not totally clear
how good it is
okay i'm going to take
now knight c5
i guess
trying to
to enter with this knight
and prevent rook a6 for the four ones
it's not clear at all this this position
something like knight d2 boxy one knight
c4 i can even suck the exchange
um yeah f3 is probably not a good idea
taking and f3
maybe
trying to
trying to say basically that this this
rook is not helping on the king's side
okay with rook here
can maybe switch all the way over
yeah yeah it's difficult for me to
okay i wanted to go king edge one rook
g1 but
yeah i will do that he still can
harass me with the rook all the time
and do this check i guess
so there's some way here to to play this
a6
okay
not sure what this does really
it protects the airport okay
um
doubling here
not sure if rook c1 was so successful
so he wants to switch over
no
queen a5 or something i mean rook g8 is
checkmate
i bet he can take h2
so it's not working right away
playing it now
maybe e4 takes
time warning
and d5
shoot i don't have any time
yeah there's this bloody contact
i need to get rid of this pin check
very badly
queen f8 checkmate this is a threat
take and queen h3 is not a mate
queen d6 queen d6
queen d8 and now bishop e5
probably
yes
i can probably defend with this move
um
check
i have no time again
okay come on
white resigns yeah well i've fought out
of this position right
check
and uh i mean isn't this isn't this good
for white i cannot believe that
it should at least be a draw or whatever
so
yeah okay what i did is probably
probably enough
this year
this is the draw
yeah i had the feeling that he was over
playing his hand here a bit
but
it's not
it's not really the case i mean
computer finds no refutation of all that
here i thought there should be something
but um
okay this rook c2 counterplay
this was of course like okay let's let's
go for it
and it's not working at all rook c4 is
excellent for black
but okay you have to just just go for it
sometimes
check
that i don't have something here is i
don't understand that really
i mean this king is very close to to be
be busted
and this would have been good yeah
probably i mean at least he has to find
he has no real move here besides queen
deform
that's not really that easy to do
causing a draw
check petrol
yeah i don't know i really don't know
very uh very very tough
okay i hope you enjoyed it this was a
tough game thanks for watching